[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
- What's the password?
- The password?
- You got it.
- The password is "password"?
- Yeah,
but see the S's are fives.
Welcome to the revolution.
[overlapping chatter]
[electronics beeping]
She's here.
- Oh. Hey, Billie.
You've awakened.
- What is going on?
- Your tactics didn't work.
You lost.
The only thing my dad
responds to...is strength.
It's time to fight fire
with flamier fire.
- Gene, I don't know
what you're planning to do,
but I know it is a bad idea.
- You know, my bad idea
was letting you be in charge
in the first place.
You were never willing
to do what it takes.
to go all the way.
- You thought a hunger strike
was called a "hunger stroke."
- Yeah, and we may never know
who was right on that one.
- It's me. I'm 100%.
- Well, perhaps.
It's that arrogance that makes
you such a weak leader.
- This is crazy.
Joy would not want any of this.
- Why don't you let
Joy tell you what Joy wants?
- Who else is in this room?
- Gene's plan might be crazy
enough to work...
white puta.
- I'm sorry...
I haven't eaten in 36 hours.
Did you just call
me a white puta?
- No. I said viva la revolución,
white puta.
- You definitely
said it that time.
- Yeah, time you did.
- I did.
- What are you planning to do?
- Let's just say tonight's
turkey is gonna be da bomb.
[laughs]
[all laughing]
- No. No!
This is a non-violent
movement!
Make love, not war!
The five dollar foot long!
- Hey, everyone, stop.
What?
- I-I don't know.
I'm feeling a little
lightheaded.
I--uh-oh.
I think I'm gonna
pass out again.
- Billie, you're fine.
- I'm passing out.
[echoes]
That would be, like,
a bunch of people using fish
to play instruments.
Is that fajitas?
I haven't eaten in 36 hours.
"Yum, fish!"
There's gonna be meat.
- So, unless you have
a better idea, viva la pizza.
- Imagine all the pizza.
Imagine.
Konichiwa.
- What's going on?
Gene, what are you doing?
- You were never willing
to go all the way.
- Words.
- [laughter]
- The S's are fives!
- Ha ha ha ha ha.
- You understand it?
It's a gun.
For violence.
- No.
[all speaking at once].
- What are you going to do?
- Let's just say
the turkey's gonna be the bomb.
The turkey will be the bomb.
The turkey will be--
- [gasps]
- The turkey's a bomb!